well [ __ ] for dinner
ain't eatin well you're not watching TV
I can't leave the house and now I can't
watch TV yeah it's called being grounded
I can't wait to move out what was that
next time I'll say it on the phone so
you can hear me no hey you're the one
who lied to me
well I'm done talking to you so don't
ever happen again
what I know you don't want to talk and
that's fine you can just listen life is
hard enough if you make good decisions
but if you make bad ones it gets even
harder nothing was gonna happen with
Janna Georgie no you always assume the
worst with me I'm sorry you're a perfect
kitten I'm just a screw-up you are not a
screw-up and I was not a perfect kid oh
what'd you do sleep through church one
morning for your information I used to
skip class so that I could drink beer in
my boyfriend's truck dad had a truck
back then not talking about your dad Wow
also stole your meemaw scar and crashed
it into a ditch really what that
boyfriend they wasn't dad missing the
point if the point is you made some bad
decisions and turned out fine
they might you being so hard on me
because some decisions you cannot walk
away from and they will affect the rest
of your life if you're talking about
Janna getting pregnant she ain't gonna
that is what I thought the next thing I
know I'm at the courthouse get married
you got married because you're pregnant
yes
so I was a mistake no no you are a
blessing the mistake was lying to my
parents so that I could spend the night
at your dad's house and you know tequila